hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear
now
i'm not sure
how exactly i first heard about this
japanese film
which is just called house or
housu
from 1977. i think it was probably on
one of those lists of like hey look at
all these crazy horror movies you need
to see like before you die or something
like that i feel like i probably saw it
on one of those and i was like huh that
sounds weird and interesting
um so yeah i think that's probably where
i first heard of it now i should note
too that this movie also started
garnering like a much bigger cult
following probably around 2009 i think
it was
because the distribution rates for it
got picked up by janice films
and then the movie got released um as
part of janus films like eclipse line
which is kind of like um i think it's
like a subset of criterion collection
but it's like more for weird cult movies
um and then like after that came out
there was a lot of uh clamor for
for the for it to like show on the big
screen so they actually like toured it
around the united states i believe in
2009 2010 something like that um in like
larger cities and in theaters and like a
lot of people went to see it so it kind
of like got a much bigger cult following
from then
so house is one of those movies that's
really kind of hard to classify
it isn't really a horror movie per se
although it is about a haunted house and
has like buckets of gore like
particularly in the third act
and i mean i guess maybe it's like sort
of a comedy like a horror comedy i guess
um the comedy is kind of bizarre and
sort of juvenile i will say that the
acting is kind of awful
the special effects are
laughably amateurish like even for 1977
but it's framed in such a way that all
of these supposed negatives actually
sort of like work in its favor if that
makes any sense
it's just a very odd
child-like
very kinetically edited little goofball
of a movie
where pretty much every single possible
thing like was just tossed at the wall
to see what would stick you know what i
mean it seems kind of like that
so like imagine if sam raimi was a
slightly disturbed and maybe faintly
horny eight nine-year-old boy who was
all coked up on like lick-a-made or
something
had access to really shitty
1970s era blue screen effects
and attempted to make the most
ridiculous live-action cartoon
imaginable like within those limitations
and you might sort of get an idea of
what you're dealing with here like what
this movie is like
i'm not really sure yet if i enjoyed
this movie or not to be honest it's
actually pretty entertaining just for
how like bafflingly batshit it is
but it seems like it was never really
intended to be taken seriously either as
a comedy or as a horror film so you know
whatever like do with that what you will
now how this movie was conceived uh goes
maybe part of the way toward explaining
the final product
though admittedly there's still uh
plenty of what the [ __ ] to be had so
in 1975 a filmmaker named nobuhiko
obayashi
who was at that point like mostly known
for making commercials and doing like
experimental films he gets approached by
toho uh studios you know who obviously
made all those kaiju movies and stuff
like that
and they asked him to come up with
something similar
to steven spielberg's massively
successful blockbuster jaws which had
just come out that year
now obayashi who had either never seen
jaws or decided he was just gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted regardless
consulted his then pre-teen daughter
chigumi for ideas about what what this
movie should be like
so a few of the ideas that she came up
with included let's have a house that
eats girls
uh let's have someone getting killed by
falling mattresses
let's have a piano eat someone's fingers
like the piano keys eat someone's
fingers let's have a watermelon that
turns into a severed head these were
like some of the things she came up with
all of these ideas i should note made it
into the final film now once the script
was finished nobody working at toho
wanted to direct it because they thought
it was nonsensical which they're
probably right about and it would
probably ruin their careers
so obayashi kind of like shrugs and is
like whatevs um i'll do it so he takes
over to direct it even though he didn't
really work for toho i guess they had
kind of like more of a contract thing
where they had all the guys that worked
under things so he didn't work there but
they were like okay whatever none of us
want to do it so you do it
now when he was casting the film he just
chose like a bunch of teenage models
that had been in some of his commercials
uh almost none of whom had any acting
experience whatsoever
now he did do the thing where i mean he
i guess he wanted to class up the joint
some so he brought in a more veteran
actress whose name was yoko minamida who
had a very substantial filmography going
all the way i think back to 1952
and uh he brought her in to play the
villain so the story of the movie such
as it is uh has to do with a group of
seven teenage girls
whose names are all very obvious markers
of their defining personality traits so
you got gorgeous who's
gorgeous
and she's also really fashionable and
she likes makeup all that kind of stuff
you got kung fu who is the strong
athletic one who duh like knows kung fu
you got fantasy who's always daydreaming
you got melody who's like the musical
one the musical prodigy
you got sweet who is
the sweet one i guess i don't know she
doesn't really she has like the least
amount of like personality of all the
other ones you got prof uh who's the
smart one who has glasses obviously and
can't see without them very very velma
and you got mac who is the fat one who's
always eating
and by fat i mean japanese fat which
actually translates to still very thin
but with a slightly rounder face than
any of the other girls so and they just
like they constantly like tease her the
whole thing it was just kind of like
she's like the chick from greece you
know like the dark hair girl that they
were always like that was always like
eating twinkies and all that other kind
of stuff but and they were always like
saying that she was fat because they
always put like in these dumpy clothes
but then like when you see her at the
end
she's totally not fat she's like pretty
much the same size as all the other ones
it's kind of like that so apparently all
these girls they all go to school
together and usually over summer
vacation they usually go to some camp or
some kind of [ __ ] i don't know
so they usually do that and their
teacher mr togo
or one of the teachers of the school i
guess uh mr togo actually sweet has a
crush on him it's a little weird and
they i guess it's either his ranch or he
goes with them or something i wasn't
real clear on like what the situation
was but this year in particular mr togo
said oh my sister had a baby and so you
guys can't come because you know family
[ __ ] or whatever so the girls have to go
someplace else for summer vacation
instead
so gorgeous who's it's really funny like
referring to her like that but that's
her name that's her name i don't think
they give her any other names any none
of the girls have any other names i
don't think that's just what their names
are
so gorgeous has i mean her dad is like
super super rich he like works in the
film industry
and they so they live in this like
really big beautiful house
and he has been in italy working on a
film i guess he does film score because
he says something about eddie and
morocco at one point so yeah so he's
doing that
now he's just come home from italy and
he's brought with him uh his new fiancee
who gorgeous has ever met who's like
half his age
and uh gorgeous is pretty put out by
this cause basically dad's like hey this
is gonna be your new mom and who you
never met before and she's just like
[ __ ] that noise so what she decides to
do she's like well i'm not going
vacation with you [ __ ] then
because i don't even know this [ __ ] um
so she doesn't say that but you know
what i mean that's kind of like the
attitude so she's like i'm gonna write
to my aunt
auntie
uh who you find out she actually hasn't
seen in 10 years and she's basically
like well can me and my friends like
come and stay at your house for the
summer she lives like somewhere really
far away like in some remote house or
something
so auntie writes back to her like writes
her a letter it's like oh oh i'm so glad
you're coming like i've been waiting for
you for years and years which like i
said that doesn't sound creepy at all
also uh during this time there's this
really adorable fluffy white kitty cat
oh my god she's such a floof it's like
so cute uh the cat's name is blanche
and the cat arrives and starts hanging
out with gorgeous and like going
everywhere with her so there's that so
immediately you're just kind of like
this cat's a witch is familiar you know
what i mean just just like i've seen
enough of these kind of movies to know
what's going on so all of the girls are
gonna go to the auntie's house for the
summer so after some kind of like silly
shenanigans that take place on the way
there like there's some random animation
there's like this really weird big fat
watermelon salesman who
i don't know there's like a whole
situation there uh so but then after all
that like the girls finally get to uh
auntie's remote house
now auntie seems nice enough uh she's
like a little bit older or that's
clearly a younger woman that they're
trying to make look older like she's got
a grey wig and stuff uh she's confined
to a wheelchair and she's kind of
lamenting like how lonely she is it's
like oh i've been waiting for you
gorgeous for so long i was so happy to
get your letter and blah blah blah but
she's like very welcoming all the girls
immediately get there and it's like oh
we're going to help you out we're going
to clean your house and we're going to
do this and then i'm like [ __ ] you're
saying my house is dirty just because
i'm in a wheelchair but you know so you
know what i mean i'm just like going off
on [ __ ] tangents but here's the weird
thing so pretty much the minute that the
girls like walk into the house crystals
like these kind of bullet-shaped crystal
things like start flying off the
chandelier and impaling various things
like kung fu kicks one of them out of
the way her name's kung fu i know i have
to keep like reminding you of that
that's the girl's name yeah so that
pretty much happens and i'm just kind of
like okay so that's how things are in
their house i mean you know there's like
again there's some witchery afoot like
you kind of suspected that because of
the whole cat situation but if you had
any doubt now you don't because you know
like [ __ ] magical chandelier crystals
that are flying around impaling
everything so you know there you go and
all the girls are just kind of like huh
well that'll happen they're just very
lazy fair about it it's very funny so
from there on out though uh the girls
start to mysteriously disappear one by
one
mac the fat one
she's the first one to vanish
she goes out in the courtyard she had
bought a watermelon from the weird uh
watermelon salesman like on the way
there
and
the okay so there's this whole thing
about like auntie says oh well she has a
refrigerator but it doesn't work like
it's out of order she says so she's like
well why don't you take the watermelon
and put it down in the well because
there's like really cold water down
there it'll keep it cold because the
refrigerator doesn't work so i'm like
okay that's how you want to do it
so so yeah so they have take this
watermelon they tie it to a rope and
they drop it down into the well
so later on mac goes out to get it
because they're like oh hey dessert time
so it's time for the watermelon and she
goes out there to get it and then she
doesn't come back
so fantasy goes out to look for her
but then when she pulls up the rope that
had the watermelon attached to the end
that's not a watermelon on the end of
the rope anymore it's actually max
severed head at the end of the rope
the head
kind of like makes a weird face and has
fangs maybe and then like it kind of
flies around and bites fantasy on the
ass and no i'm not making that up that
actually does happen in the movie so
fantasy tells the other girls about this
but when they all go out to check the
head is just a melon again and they all
tease fantasy for being you know fantasy
prone which
i mean the name's right there on the tin
so i don't really know what they
expected from her but okay so then later
on as it goes on uh this is kind of like
like i said these girls are just like
walking around in what is essentially
like a weird like pee-wee's playhouse
except with murder so sweet one of the
other girls she gets assaulted by
falling futons at one stage
and when the other girls dig through the
pile of futons and blankets and [ __ ]
like looking for her all they find is
all her clothes and they're like oh she
must have stripped and then like one of
the girls like picks up
her panties and like sniffs them and
then they're like making a joke about
something smells funny in here so i'm
just like really i'm like this really i
was like did that just happen did that
girl just sniff her friend's panties and
i'm like yeah that just happened oh my
god yeah so there was that whole thing
uh it's a little weird so then there's a
scene later too where melody is playing
the piano like to cheer because like i
said it's melody so she's like the
musical prodigy or whatever so they're
like hey melody why don't you play the
piano to like cheer everybody up because
of all this like weird haunting [ __ ]
that's going on and while she's doing it
like the keys
like eat her fingers and she's like okay
with it at first she's like look my
fingers are gone like they ate my
fingers then like he eats her whole hand
and then the piano like eats the rest of
her and then like her various body parts
like a leg and an arm and stuff like
kind of hanging out like flopping around
like outside of the thing and like her
head and she's just kind of like smiling
about it like it's the coolest thing
ever and then like her
detached fingers are like playing the
thing it's it's it's weird it's weird
it's real weird so it's just you know
the inside of the
of the piano is just like all red it's
just kind of like that that solarized
looking that effect i can't remember
what it's called but you see it in like
real shitty like cheap
uh music videos and kids shows and stuff
like that like from the 70s and early
80s where everything like looked those
super saturated like colors like
solarization i think they called it so
it looks like that like on the inside of
the piano now among the other weird
[ __ ] things that happened in this
movie uh kung fu later gets devoured by
a lamp
um
or i guess it's not a lamp it's kind of
like like a hanging it's not a
chandelier exactly but it's just kind of
like a hanging light fixture
um gorgeous at some point goes into a
mirror dimension
there's like a f blood flood like the
like blood floods through the house and
ends up like dissolving prof the smart
one who by the way is naked when all
this happens because reasons auntie also
has remember that broken fridge i was
talking about earlier she the reason she
didn't want anybody going in there was
because the refrigerator is actually
like a secret passage but then when they
open it later like it looks like a
normal refrigerator so if she's can like
witchy
like witchy powers and like make it look
like a normal refrigerator why didn't
you want them looking in there i don't
know it doesn't make any sense oh and
also like toward the end uh mr togo like
is coming out there to see them and
he gets scared at the watermelon
salesman place and he because he gets
scared he turns into a pile of bananas
so there's that um
none of it
really makes the slightest lick of sense
uh but it sort of works i have to say
like in an acid trippy fever dreamy kind
of way um since the house itself is kind
of established as a space where
absolutely anything cannon does happen
so it's like a fun house type of thing
and like i said it's like it seemed like
they didn't really
think about
uh you know having any kind of like plot
structure they're just kind of like well
they're all gonna go to this house and
then like just the craziest [ __ ] we can
imagine is gonna happen almost like i
said it's almost kind of like you can
you can tell that like a kid
conceived this you know what i'm saying
she's like oh and then she goes in this
room and then like a piano eats her you
know what i mean it's just it doesn't
make any sense but it's not really meant
to you know what i'm saying now believe
it or not uh there is kind of sort of a
story behind auntie and behind what the
deal with the house well not so much the
house but kind of more about anti i
guess
so it turns out the ante
back in the day
used to be engaged to this handsome
young fella who went off to fight in
world war ii and he promised her that he
would return to her
but he never did presumably because he
was killed in the worm but ante was
convinced that because he had promised
then he was absolutely gonna come back
and all she had to do was wait for him
now she died while she was still waiting
and i guess her bitterness or whatever
or it was some kind of like curse or
spell or something where you know she
was like waiting forever but whatever it
was it essentially like turned her into
this evil ghost witch type of being
who gains energy
from eating
unmarried young girls who wander into
her orbit because naturally also
her powers come from the cat i think
i don't know because there's kind of a
whole thing where they're like we have
to we have to kill the cat that'll like
make her just and i'm just like okay but
i don't know it doesn't like i said
don't don't think about it too hard i'm
thinking about it too hard and it's like
giving me a migraine uh so yeah i don't
know like the powers come from the cat
maybe they don't i have no idea what's
going on and at one point like gorgeous
after gorgeous goes through the mirror
she seems to become i guess because
she's the ancestor so she's not just
gonna be like eaten or whatever but she
goes through the mirror and seems to
become like the new incarnation of
auntie like she comes out and she's got
like the big bridal outfit on and
everything and then i think everybody
else dies like all the other kids like
all the other girls
and at the very end gorgeous's hated new
potential stepmom who i had absolutely
forgotten existed at this point in the
movie because of all the crazy [ __ ] that
happened and it was just kind of i was
like wait who's this now oh yeah she was
like in in the scene for like two
minutes at the beginning of the movie
this is the stepmom that she was mad
about uh yeah she turns up at the house
for some reason uh at the end and then
when she gets there like all the house
is all fixed up because remember there
was a whole blood flood and like an
eating piano and all that other kind of
stuff but it's all fixed up now
and but only gorgeous is there and she's
wearing like a very classic kimono
and basically she's saying oh i'm so
glad you're here potential stepmom i
can't remember her name was but she's
like oh the other girls she's like where
are the other girls at and she's like oh
they'll wake up when they're hungry so
you know what i mean so you're led to
presume they all died and
uh are now like evil ghosts too that are
like feeding off anybody that comes in
the house i'm guessing as you know what
i mean i'm just
i'm just like
that's that's just the impression that i
got so
just as though as you could tell i'm
kind of struggling
just as this is a very difficult movie
to describe it's also kind of difficult
to recommend not because it's bad
necessarily but it's one of those movies
that you have to have like a certain
kind of like mindset and certain kind of
proclivities to even like want to watch
this in the first place i mean by all
means if you're
really into
weird japanese movies from the 1970s uh
you'll probably get a kick out of it but
anybody that isn't versed in this type
of real whimsical
cinematic quirkiness like it's kind of
like oh it's set up almost like a weird
kid's show but then there's like
dismemberment and like buckets of blood
and it's just like really gory and stuff
like that it's just very very bizarre
it's a very very bizarre juxtaposition
yeah so if if you're not already kind of
like into that kind of [ __ ] and you're
not kind of willing to meet it on its
own terms
then you'll probably
have a hard time you might like lose
patience you know you won't be able to
get past these little janky special
effects even though you know the
director said that well we did it like
that on purpose because we wanted to
make it look like a kid made it which
like i said you know i was like yeah
he's just succeeded there um but yeah
and you know the acting's very silly uh
the plot is senseless it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever but all
that said uh it's actually like a pretty
fun little movie for all that uh though
i will recommend that you maybe indulge
in some adult beverages beforehand or
maybe some chemicals of choice uh
while you're watching it just in order
to get the full experience um
i don't know though you might want to
not you might want to like take it easy
like too much on the hallucinogens
because this might give you like some
really bad
this might set you off on a really bad
trip because there's like some very very
strange
uh
imagery in this one but yeah it's one of
those movies that i feel like if you're
into like weird-ass cinema then you
should probably see it at least once
because it's just it's pretty out there
it's not the weirdest thing i've ever
seen but
it's pretty weird and it's just it's
kind of like fascinating
how something like that gets made uh so
yeah i don't know just
if you've seen it like let me know if
you know what i'm talking about
i actually watched it on hbo max this
actually like i said it's you know it
came out on like subset of like
criterion collections so it's in their
amc like classic curated section uh so
if you want to watch it on there you can
i'm sure it's streaming elsewhere but
let me know if you've uh seen it and
we'll have a discussion about it in the
comments and that'll do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye